[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'une amitié
c'est l'histoire de Nicki Mina 27 ans et
Sofia 25 ans
elles sont esthéticiennes
[Musique]
ce tournage a commencé au lendemain de
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans le 15
août 2021 les nouveaux maîtres de
l'Afghanistan ont fait une promesse au
monde entier ils ont changé
[Musique]
le salon de Sophia et niggina se trouve
dans le centre de Kaboul
une vingtaine d'employés ils travaillent
7 jours sur 7
[Musique]
est un sanctuaire de femme où les hommes
n'entre pas on s'y retrouve pour se
faire belle se réconforter parler du
pays
[Musique]
le salon de nickina et Sofia accueille
le gratin de Kaboul des vedettes des
actrices des femmes afghanes qui vont se
marier
[Musique]
le salon est aussi un refuge pour notre
caméra pendant plus d'un an nous
échapperons à la vigilance des talibans
il surveille avec application les
endroits comme celui-ci
[Musique]
pour réviser ses cours elle partage son
temps entre les séances de maquillage et
ses études de littérature anglaise à
l'université
et le soir quand les clients ne sont
partis c'est un parfum de liberté qui
envahit le salon
comme si à l'extérieur rien n'avait
changé
[Musique]
quelques semaines après le retour au
pouvoir les talibans rouvrent les
universités pour les filles à condition
qu'elle n'y côtoie pas les hommes
ni du 9 et sa rentrée
[Musique]
notre caméra n'est pas la bienvenue ni
Gina filme la suite avec son téléphone
portable
[Musique]
pourra-t-elle rester faudra-t-il partir
pour voyager il lui faudra un passeport
et pour l'obtenir beaucoup de patients
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les émissions
[Musique]
[Rires]
à mesure que les talibans imprime leur
marque les Afghans descendent dans la
rue pour défendre leurs droits
[Musique]
la foule chaque fois avec un peu plus de
vigueur
ce jour-là les militants ne sont
embarqués au poste de police
elles sont relâchées en fin de journée
sous la pression de la communauté
internationale
[Musique]
les filles ont rendez-vous avec l'une
des manifestantes
à résou vient tout juste d'être libéré
s ont été arrêtés et séquestrés par les
talibans pendant des semaines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde en parle dans le salon
pour Zakia qui s'est battu pour en
arriver là ce n'est pas si simple
[Musique]
le salon de beauté c'est toute sa vie
c'est l'été la misère s'installe les
règles se durcissent encore les afghan
meurent de faim mais les talibans ont
d'autres priorités
comme celles d'interdire aux Afghans de
passer leur permis de conduire
[Musique]
après des mois d'efforts
le passeport de niggina arrive enfin
[Musique]
un passeport et tout devient possible
dans quelques jours dans quelques
semaines c'est sûr elle partiront
en attendant il faut fêter ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis trois jours nigina ne vient plus
au salon
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les talibans fêtent leur première année
au pouvoir et les pays occidentaux
facilitent les procédures de visa pour
les femmes
la nouvelle s'est répandue auprès des
Afghans elle tente leur chance comme
Sofia
demain elle part pour le Pakistan là-bas
et lui fera une demande de visa pour
l'Europe
[Musique]
ce train a pour destination Paris gare
de Lyon
[Musique]
je viens d'Afghanistan j'habite à
Beauchamps
j'ai 24 ans j'ai 24 ans
je suis coiffeuse alors on va voir un
petit peu les nombres je crois qu'on a
vous connaissez jusqu'à 10
[Musique]
3 4 5
je vous souhaite une bonne semaine
à la semaine prochaine
Sofia vient à côté de Paris elle occupe
une petite chambre dans un centre
d'hébergement pour demandeurs d'asile
c'est là qu'elle attend son statut de
réfugiés aux côtés d'autres exilés
afghan
elles sont devenues ses amis
[Musique]
contre les Afghans
elles sont maintenant exclues de la
majorité des emplois
les salons de beauté n'ont pas encore
été fermés ils sont en sursis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les deux femmes ont 48 heures pour
profiter l'une de l'autre pas une de
plus ce sont les règles du Centre
d'hébergement de Sophia
[Musique]